reject nation we have our supernatural
shirts on today why because I got we're
gonna watch today from Supernatural
conventions our homeboy ash this one's
called story stories and more stories
maybe the first time in a while we use
the actual title of the video
compilation of supernatural conventions
go subscribe to this channel and tell me
if your supernatural fan that's well
worth it usually we do these at the
beginning of the month but Ash
specifically said and you wait till
after recover season 5 episode 15 which
we have done speaking of which over at
our patreon page it's time to plug it we
do a weekly Q&A podcast and we also do
TV show watch along several of those
shows have reaction highlights included
the biggest draw of course would be
supernatural which for a while we will
be covering twice a week and in other
shows that have reaction highlights
included along with watch Long's or dr.
who my hero academia attack on Titan
JoJo's Bizarre Adventure Death Note
haunt ohonta
promise Neverland code geass Full Metal
Alchemist Brotherhood violet ever
guarded Demon Slayer one punch man and
then there are shows where we only have
the watch along for them which are
agents of shield and Gotham and then we
also do music video reactions two to
three times a week on top of that so go
become up hey try eject today I'm sure
you're sick of me talking about it let's
do this
that was written there was an episode
where Sam and the other guy and I'm
switching instead originally they had
sang all buddies well the whole body
swap episode originally it was Sam and
Dean doing the body swap that would have
been really fun the way that was funny
wasn't that great but I think the
logistics of trying to remember who's
doing what they wanted to see Sam
whether Sam was kind of whether Jared
was going to play Sam and another
person's body or whether Tara's gonna
pretend to be another person they if he
did that little choose him that the best
way to do it was with that sort of
Cameron Turner
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
the supernatural bro Mario
[Music]
the final episode
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
let me say not apologize to groups
[Applause]
he loves these conventions eventually
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
they're generous
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
there's I notice there's like paramedics
attending to this one just one young
lady and they walk by and just kind of
take notice
she's actually sitting on chair actually
kind of like talk to her and as I walk
by paradise
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
and so I see this coming
I can't actor black hat off in the class
so I get up I get up for work 7x my way
you know walk a few yards over this way
and she
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
and they start walking over with her
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
yeah
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
I refuse
it's just the competitive nature we
never used to have that bright something
in the script that I can't do or that I
won't figure out how to do I remember
what they were like over than he has
been reversed palladium Hollow
so I spent the whole hour of lunch learn
have no reverse 180 the Apollo which is
in a modern car easier in the 1967 tank
very very heavy and it's Friday goes
my name is Melanie wait to be told that
there was another one cleaning all the
weapons breaking them all our Kamala
back together always so cool without any
time yeah
where's the one that Phil wanted me to
do so I forget what season that was but
there's an episode where Dee has like
shotgun pistol two pistols and a shotgun
all laid out photo when he's clean again
and I never look down but I put the
whole thing back together again bracket
put it down
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
professional awesome feature Milan
started to finish it
[Music]
please don't sing about
[Music]
just relax or something like let's move
on like if there's some there's some
detail in the background or something
like this like acidulous just maybe
slightly different than what we used for
the same reason and it's on a certain
page and then you know this day on set
people will say this a lot a lot of
sesame recesses Douglas if they're
paying attention to that we've lost
[Music]
[Applause]
president
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
never spend that
I like the nerd HQ business model I want
another maybe was a speaks any good boy
Thank You ash that was so funny as you
halfway through is like this one are we
talking to right now
perfect inflection oh boy I love Jensen
Ackles I just love Jensen Ackles
you're reminds me of me would be
exceptionally a million million million
times better looking and cooler but in
no way of like if you're telling some
long story and I'm just trying to think
of a joke be like I can see him thinking
of a joke and waiting for his time to
like insert a joke but try to be
straight-faced about it yeah it's on the
car so yeah I'm more like that in
conversation I try to let people know a
little bit more now when I'm joke that's
the first of any conversation I'll often
be doing that with people like that's
where I was knows oh my god man I just
love this guy so much when jared is
telling his story which was so freakin
funny about there's nothing about him
where it could be you didn't actually
think you were dead but then there's
this part of me that actually does
believe and I'm more likely to believe
that he actually did think he was dead
just based off the collection of stories
you've heard from the guy so far maybe
for at least a moment if not like an
entire stretch of time before finding
another human being I mean yeah it's a
little bit as he was burying was going
into like a bit territory
it's a big fortune apparently this guy
probably really thought he was dead did
any you really believed you you're out
in the middle of nowhere the car crashes
and and you lost your phone you can't
hear it yeah I think like yeah for a
moment maybe you might entertain a funky
idea and he's been doing so much of
letting his mind
dive in in terms of playing Sam perhaps
you know like I have fathom to believe
there's a mind some kind of purgatory Oh
what Jensen's like the way he's just
listening in this timing like he just
found like the perfect moment to
interrupts into the jug you know you
know he's got like certain jokes on his
mind and he's just waiting for that and
moment didn't like the right moment some
window enter Apple arias does enjoy yeah
their chemistry there back and forth is
just effortless it's weird when Jordan
pokes fun or makes like edgy jokes the
crowd often reacts and uh-oh they don't
expect it from him I think he just seems
so sweet so nice I mean the Jarrod
that's like if I make an edgy joke
expected from Jensen yeah kind of be a
little bit more the guy who ribs that's
like you're the Charlie Sheen to the
Emilio Estevez to the Catherine girl
yeah oh me Jensen said it wouldn't it
just wouldn't be his because it's funny
other way that the personality both from
the show and also that I'm sure has just
grown through the convenience probably
plays a factor and like it's so tangible
the energy back and forth between them
and the crowd as well it's not just that
it's them it's also the the room with
Jensen he has this unique thing the most
dressed example I can think of when I
watch Wolverine that's such a badass
dude and then I watch Hugh Jackman in
like you're nothing serious yeah you're
very expressive
cheery it's beyond the Australian accent
like he's so expressive and right eyes
my friend he's kind of got a bit of a
flamboyant personality at times he's the
antithesis to Wolverine Jensen yeah I
don't think he's like a dude who's like
picking fights and [ __ ] he's obviously
more in tune with his emotions then the
portrayal of Dean Winchester
he just
seems like such a cool TV was cool and
he also seems like very laid-back this
was the most laid-back at least in
certain moments that I've seen Jared
it's funny to watch them both tell a
story and laid-back fashion because like
Jensen well like you know obviously just
sitting back and kind of waiting for his
moment on the Jared story like that
Kirby bit was such like a little
adventure in and of itself and it's
funny how Jared never in ER because I'm
used to them interrupting each other yet
amid all other stories every once in a
while you you'd see the think we haven't
have a microwave you'd see that they
were like they're they're doing that
like about this they watch it but then
they choose not to letting them just
have their turn to tell their stories
for the most part which was rewarding in
and of itself
yeah that Kirby story was something I
mean anybody must go through that kind
of crap all the time though I would
imagine yeah I mean it's just the
specificity of this particular
experience being at like such a formal
gathering and then half-ass like weird
moment where it's like people are
fanning out but they're also trying to
be professional and do their jobs and
tend to somebody who's in a bad way I
think that was great because both
stories had like such outlandish details
to a certain extent they're these
perfect little vivid portraits although
that one felt pretty much I could see
the whole thing I mean with it with him
being you know Jensen Ackles with him
being as attractive of a male specimen
as he is I mean around drunk a drunk
girl I could just imagine the level of
that like the worst wasn't even that bad
like I've been approached by drunk
people before okay will you rejects Greg
I've said once I'm at the Renaissance
Fair I had that with this one guy who
got the impression was actually
following me around he looked like older
a little bit older than me but he was
with a group of people he was the only
one he knew who I was right is it a
group of people and this dude was
clearly wasted all right oh so
recognizes me it's pretty rare so if
someone recognizes me I'm like yeah yeah
I'm really welcoming of it especially
these days but then when I'm like caught
in line and I'm like did you follow me
to a liger that's a pretty big of it
just happened to be behind me again and
then yeah I feel like I see you looking
at me right that's sort of I just
imagine on a level of being this kind of
famous you know yeah you got to wonder
what the scarier experience is the less
amusing experiences are never been
stalked when you have family I imagine
that's when years like he said he was
kidding out of it and I could imagine
this little horse you know when you grow
up if you're like born into a lifestyle
where your dad or mom is already famous
I imagine there's no real appreciation
for it but I wonder if your kid is like
maybe close to 10 years old or something
and then their parent becomes famous if
they like that their parent is famous
yeah if it's like I can imagine if you
grow up with it it can become annoying
or maybe you're just used to it yeah you
don't really care that much because this
has always been a part of life yeah but
I wonder if you like it if you're a
parent Pop's you're old enough to
understand any of that is you don't
really hear about those stories there's
some pretty interesting stuff in your
like the one with the forgetting the
actresses name but she was talking about
how when it was her coverage cuz I've
heard those stories many times of actors
I've had actor friends in mind who have
admitted especially for like the really
emotional intense scenes you kind of
have to save up some of that fuel for
when the cameras on you especially if
you're having it close-up yeah you know
you it's like you want to be giving at
the same time you don't want to do the
money shot off yeah so I thought it was
great to hear that when it's not their
coverage a they don't let their
stand-ins just be there especially when
they are famous and they are the stars
of the show they could easily just
bugger off yeah
you have cardboard cutouts if they
wanted to yeah they gotta have a stand
in Carrboro cutouts whatever but they
they decided to be in for him and they
decided to give an actual solid
performance that way they can get the
best out of the the actress it was on
camera you don't hear that story that
often and when you do it might sound
like some of them might not be a big
deal but you got to imagine when you
have like these many many hours a day
filming and then you're trying to just
reserve your big emotional moments for
when the cameras on you it's act it's
cool to be selfless in that department
to be a generous the I think that's the
term that's better
generous giving actor mm-hmm well it's
got to be really awesome to for that
guest star to be able to like and I'm
sure if they applied that same thing to
other guests yes you know it's got to be
an honor to be able in fact they thought
she was experience is very yeah we both
got to be in the scene with yeah like
that's a that's a pretty cool thing as a
supporting actor to get to do is like
act so really act with you know the
stars of the show or whatever and not
just have it be kind of half acting or
having edited together as though it
looks like you're acting yeah those
stars and you know these are convention
personalities and even if these were
just interviews where it's like
one-on-one you never really know what a
person's like right you just don't even
the vice versa for you guys peering in
at us yeah you really don't know we are
terrible human beings I love we I I
can't stand John I get the impression
they are at least you know in terms of
the professional environment they are
they do their best to have good people
skills little moments they seem to
really care about remembering people's
names and that goes a long way
especially at the level they're at work
lot of times I don't need to remember
certain people's names like whom Jared's
telling a story
oh yeah the producers show analysis ten
days like the producers assistance shows
up and he's like I think his name's Eric
like he cares to try to give a proper
name call out yeah you know but even in
with feeding with their fans when
they're interacting with them and it
looked like at one point even Jensen got
up while Jarrett was telling his death
story to like give someone a water
bottle or something yeah well that's
always fun to to watch them like
interact with people like well one's
telling a story and see the other
looking off camera and I'm like yeah I
want to be there yeah I want to be
caught up on the show so I can go to the
next one when the World Bank okay I
think the the to like actual
supernatural story related ones would be
the body swap which we covered already
or were several episodes past that and
then we had talked we had touched on
that idea in our review of that episode
about what if they had done a different
approach on the filming of the episode
itself with you know portraying Sam just
as himself in the kids clothes versus
having him do it aggression but also
having just the two Sam and Dean bodies
why and I remember being like is
I I guess I liked it but being let down
and then the comments were like don't
care for this epic of the supernatural
fans this is like a good chunk in the
very beginning that's dedicated to that
episode I thought that was interesting
to hear about it because hearing what
they originally wanted to do
instantaneously I was thinking that
would be a much better episode I would
have much rather have watched that and
random teen which boy yeah that almost
seems like it maybe could have just been
an earlier seasons episode or something
like that if they wanted to use it in
that particular day because the setup
itself is more whimsical whereas if you
had Sam and Dean body swap you could
probably do a lot of character
developing within that and be fun
because they know each other's
performances so well so they can embody
it yeah cuz yeah it's so yeah and then
you know like the sigils that Jared
struggles with their department you're
always picking out the little legging
consistent bad continuity it's funny how
yeah I just won't think about oh yeah
they don't do that themselves dude a
like he has to yes I do like some of it
right yes agile he's as he was saying
but there was actually a prop guy who's
painting it on then when they but it's
time for his coverage he has to do the
rest of the painting for it I am not
good at art and what whatsoever any time
I play any kind of art game there's just
like poor game that we'd love to play
called scroll I like it's your drawings
alright no one ever could tell what's
right it's always no good ever tell what
I'm drawing as I suck I just I'm
terrible at drawing
if someone's able to get it people are
always because people associate what I
do is like I don't know what Greg's try
to do yeah or is with you every everyone
when you will we play a trying
everyone's like wow yeah too much to do
such short time
panic oh yeah especially if you're in a
situation where you're being like that
at least you're able to draw off the
dome or off an idea yeah if you're
supposed to just look at an image and
they go okay I'm gonna draw made up
series of squiggles you know and and
geometric shapes I can imagine that yeah
especially on a show where you have to
see so many of them over time and that's
the thing is I guess I would be curious
as to you
if those are totally made-up how much
people would notice and consistency
between them or not but usually within
the sigil drawings it's so handheld and
so edited yeah she's like coding back
and forth and didn't you care you can
mask it I've never noticed any
inconsistencies but I think you can mask
if there's an inconsistency pretty
easily on that less so if it's just like
the book is open to an entirely
different page and like most of the bow
I'll notice things like that all the
time I'll notice it when it's even if
it's sometimes an actor heads in the
spider-man one to a few guys until the
scene spider around one it's clearly
Tobey Maguire has the screenplay in
front of him it's a scene where he's
talking with atmae and you could tell
with the highlighting on and I'm like
that's a script in front of him tell me
I'm wrong there I you tell me I'm wrong
but I'm like what else would it be look
at it it's obvious he's in school thank
you so much ash for putting this
together supernatural convention
subscribe to the channel today you can
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification well make sure to follow us
on patreon and last but not least
Anissa Olivia
this is gonna be the easiest shout out
in the world you know why she gave John
that shirt that's right and she gave
Greg into that shirt so our supernatural
tease the only ones we now own that's
right and and sorry I took his home I
did it belongs
I said you can and now I'm regretting
giving him the permission when he's
specifically it was like so should I put
this year and I was like don't dude it's
yours just take you long take it take it
to back to your bedroom now we're doing
this I'm like oh this is what he was
probably thinking about funkopop
and I got the Dean one and he got the
Sam ones right so Aneesa thank you so
much you found our secret p.o box it was
we made it extra hard for you and that's
how we know John hey Chad's office she's
just at my house
very efficient if you're looking for all
kinds of thing seriously thank you thank
you love and generosity and for really
lending us fan credibility yeah for a
super people see it they're like oh wow
they must be huge supernatural fans
damn right almost at the sixties right
we're we're like a third of the way
through the show thank you see you I'm
sorry I sigh blow kisses people think
I'm gonna wink but I do this that I go
[Laughter]